ah okay hi my name is markiplier welcome
to three scary games oh my god
I'm recording oh [ __ ] okay that was
weird
this one's called no players online
there are no players online Wow okay
hang on Oh weird so this is offline so
that's a no-go I don't know I
Wow what the hell oh God
Oh weird okay so I should have read up
on this guy I like to jump into these as
blind as possible but I I suppose I
should have read up okay it's like quake
graphics I get five bullets per that
there's no other players online so fat a
lot of good that's gonna do hey I'm
coming for you baby I'm gonna come get
your flag I think I think that's the
main objective here hey whoa weird well
let's not jump into the abyss just yet
let's find out what we have going on
here this is bizarrely reminiscent of
the feeling that you would actually get
if you were playing a game that no
longer has an active user base you see
it a lot on indie horror games that have
like a multiplayer component or just
indie games in general sometimes there's
just knowing that plays
I guess I'm just gonna go get the flag
hey look it's their flag let's just go
take that this is weird I know it's got
something in store for me I've got the
flag looking for players I don't know
what to will excuse me
why are you go darker why you go dark
[Music]
[Music]
okay ah Hey I didn't mean to I didn't
mean to oh is it me too
oh yes no what I meant to do wars -
accidentally shooting people you know
how it is these guns
the rampant desire to get a good kill
death ratio you know how it is I gotta
make the pro-gamer moves I am a pro
gamer after all I'm here to
professionally game my word what is it
oh no I see what I'm seeing up there
there's some up there oh I'm coming to
get you you think you can escape from me
oh oh what was that oh you want to run
that by me again
who was hiding behind it a tree what's
going on here oh I don't like this oh I
don't like this none at all who was over
here huh huh huh you think you're gonna
keep me from scoring this flag here I'll
just run in a distraction play that's
all it is that's all it is
that's all you are just a bunch of
distractions for me getting this victory
kaboom baby boom I did it I'm the best
yeah that's right that's what here's
what I thought GG easy am i right
everybody why is it glowing red
or it's probably fine
that is the red team over there so I'm
just guessing it's just trying to
illuminate my path to the where the
where the flag would be which we would
obviously be over this way but you know
in case I get lost I thought I saw
something
oh that's very red oh that oh I don't
know I'm going for baby oh well we're
done now
okay good what about the photo graph
anything weird going on with the photo
graph ooh sorry bud okay okay okay okay
it's all good I didn't need to do that
but I did it anyway just to make sure
they know who's the boss around here no
they know I mean business I mean like
401 K 1099 business I'm here to I got
the flag there's no that place is Gabe
no one plays this game as far as I was
concerned hello who's there huh you're
ready I'm I'm getting less bullets every
time I don't Oh like that they're not
giving me enough bullets what oh god I
thought I saw something back there
getting spooked by my own shadow here
you're not stopping me I'm gonna score
this I'm scoring baby you can't stop it
you can't like one bullet really that's
all I get now
you see garbage sometimes I have one
sometimes I don't doesn't make a lot of
sense but okay whatever you think you
can mess with me the answer is you
cannot yeah oh what's this oh crushing
victory oh yeah oh okay told you to hold
my toes
you're not gonna tow my toes you ain't
gonna tow my toes you toes my toes we're
toes all of our toes yeah I got ten toes
what are you dealing with that tree is
disappearing into peer that tree wasn't
there
I'm not crazy that tree was not there
when I whoa sorry that tree wasn't there
there was one tree before it was normal
let's get this looks good this job let's
get this sweet dub wait what's in a tree
back here before the last time I went
here it's really weird guys things is
changing things has changed good things
has changing by Ed actually not good the
opposite of good the bad thing hey your
doors open shouldn't believe it
someone's gonna sneak in the back way
oh I can't go that way it's okay I
didn't need to I got the flag baby I'm
about to get this sweet dog oh hell yeah
I don't even know who they're dealing
with here oh sorry your game was ruined
as soon as ma RK i p li er walked in the
door there's a tree missing there too
now well whatever man
not today oh boy you were right listen
buddy you wanna mess with the likes of
me go you want to slow down throw down
you better slow down - you better throw
down Hey well you hate to see it
do not move another step whatever you do
do not deliver that flag how did you
even get access to this game whoa no no
no can you hear me la dee dee you can
read this press Y and chat to say
something
oh not can't do it okay well too late
boo boo wait never mind I don't think
you have chat permission on this server
go back
what why do not deliver that flag oh
just shoot twice if you can read this
okay I can read you I'm reading you so
let me explain oh I don't know if I want
you to explain if you deliver that last
flag the service will shut down I
absolutely cannot let that happen
I've been working on this project for
more than 11 years I can't let you
jeopardize all of my work this may look
like a simple FPS game to you
but this game has the power to raise the
dead oh yeah that makes sense
that at least that's what it's supposed
to do are you oh so casual project it's
still a work in progress as you can
probably tell yeah yeah I'm making this
talk and see my wife again oh that's so
sad yeah it's real sad but she seems to
be stuck in a sort of limbo uh-huh okay
you probably already met her oh yeah
she's lovely she might come over a bit
of ggressive but she's just scared and
confused
okay can you blame her you destroyed the
record player with her favorite music
well I didn't mean to I used that to
keep her calm I didn't mean it if you
deliver that last flag or soul will be
set free but I know I can save her and
bring her back okay please press escape
and shut down the game please well
oh but you know I could also delivered
the flag please don't
Wow why no no no do not deliver that
flag well go back to the center of the
map what why why what's in the center
what's in the center what's in the
center Johnny boy what's in the center
huh what's in the center of the map also
weird game to resurrect your wife and
Wyatt why an FPS game the center of the
map hmm you talking about this little
alcove over here you talking about
little alcove II is this the center of
the map hello okay well if you're not
gonna talk to me that I ain't gonna do
nothing about nothing to you I didn't
mean to destroy the record player I just
I didn't think the music was very
comforting anyway I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna listen to you because you do
you're not talking to me so I'm gonna
slap this flag right in its flag hole
and there's nothing you can do it to
stop me here I go go back what if I go
no no no go back that nap let's see what
happens slam right there oh oh oh
well [ __ ] I may have goofed that a
little bit maybe I wasn't supposed to do
that okay
oh [ __ ] what have I done
oh please shall be a permanent thing
please oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] it is a prop god
oh no oh no okay I've got a way around
this guys don't you worry let me worry
about worry don't you worry about worry
let me worry about worry okay wait wait
wait wait wait wait okay wait someone
said this might work this might work
this is my work I have no idea ah this
might help this might be a joke I have
no idea this this might work okay
everybody hold onto your butts
I've been hold onto your butts nothing
here up up down down left right left
right BA oh wow
all right cool um I'm about that I'm
pretty about that okay okay so let's
let's do the speed run baby speed run
I'm not gonna break the music box this
time around you ain't gonna trick me
like that okay all right Oh trees God
okay
everything seems Samos ammo why are you
why are you here again
hey I don't know please just leave us
alone wait a minute oh yeah buddy you
want to mess with the likes of me but
you want to mess with the likes of me oh
yeah buddy yeah you think you can go
toe-to-toe with this guy no no's you
cannot you can't go on any of my toes
all right where's he's probably waiting
by the flag drop-off but I'm just being
you know thorough just make sure he's
not speaking up on me not spawn camping
or nothing I'm just making sure okay hey
buddy Johnny boy Oh Johnny boy Johnny
boy Arnold sue Johnny boy
where you at Johnny boy Johnny boy
where's Johnny boy I don't know where
Johnny boy
oh ho John a John Oh
I can't read that or tell what it is
it's like a squiggly line what
I mean could you film this on something
other than a piece of asparagus wait oh
wait wait
that was a map that was an arrow on it
enter it looked like an enter button
whoa what is that what is that what is
that there's something there it was like
it was pointing to keys
that led to the enter button there's a
code it's that's what that's
representing it's bracket Oh bracket
that's like the down-up-down
I don't have that drawing is anyone have
like a picture of that drawing okay I
can't figure this out for the life of me
for the life of me I cannot figure this
out there's a deeper mystery here and I
think I'm on the right track with this
because I believe that the code is
simpler than people would probably
assume it to be it is just a diagram of
buttons on the keyboard and it goes down
up down down up down up down down up
down down up down up down up up down up
and bracket circle bracket is part of it
I don't know so I don't have time to put
her through all of these different
confirmations but there is a secret here
so we'll leave it at that but we are not
done there's been an intense game yes
but we are not done three scary games
must move on so this next one is a game
all right this next one is a game called
flesh birds I don't know what that means
but it don't look too friendly all right
let's do this
hey bird are you doing anyway I just
gotta go you guys don't eat me please oh
boy well they're gonna eat me aren't
they
I'm gonna get ed up I know this for a
fact I'm gonna get it it must be like
the era of PlayStation 1 graphics there
must have been like a game jam or
something with this level of graphics
that just brought along a lot of cool
ideas it's always well that's not good
oh yeah
the ominous music confirms that that is
definitely most definitely not good oh
that is a big hole heap and helping and
not good oh that's what you call C okay
all right wow that's a lot of Boyd's oh
Jesus okay what am I supposed to do
behave
my god was that me I didn't stand a
chance but didn't even play please tell
me that wasn't me all right good get
well what oh boy oh they say it's a hard
job but they had me sold with a good pay
a good paycheck in this field is hard to
come by and I'm lucky that my family
have allowed me to travel this far
of course the wife wasn't happy but I'm
here they say this Forester stood for
centuries I was certain the plans had
come together to work this place but
developments must follow through I don't
know but don't start working till Monday
so I've been enjoying her being hunted
here in the wild for once gives me a
break from the bloody rat race back in
the city blueberries seem to grow all
around the place and some for breakfast
today bloody lovely it's a shame we're
here to take it all away but a job is a
job and I need to put food on the table
all right cool hey how you couldn't
please everyone ran to that old church
I've stayed here yeah I don't know you
may actually be the smart one here Wow
all right everybody I'm gonna go run to
the old church see you around buddy
see you around gotta keep up if you want
a roll with the big boys hey have you
checked out a heist with markiplier yet
if you haven't you're missing out it's
pretty amazing
or maybe you checked it out and you
haven't gotten all the endings it's my
latest interactive story 31 endings it's
amazing really really proud of it okay
alright blueberries I'll get some boobs
and have some boobs oh yeah yeah leave
none for the boy I'll leave some for the
boys
oh my god you can't do that to me that
is unfair oh good this will help oh yeah
one [ __ ]
Oh God Oh Oh what whomp-whomp get down
Oh slides holy crap holy crap
Oh God hey hey hey how oh okay okay Wow
why are those in 3d and all the people
are 2d no wonder they didn't stand a
chance
no get what I've been up a net bird food
okay yeah that makes sense okay yeah
that yeah I didn't do too good okay good
here I am okay good great this is going
swimmingly all right let's try the skin
G yeah come on hit him Danny hit him Oh
two-for-one sale three-for-one sale I
got all of them
okay I can run a little faster if I dag
and I'll strafe so I'm gonna do that oh
you Oh shooty shooty tutti it's so many
good oh yeah one come all not one thing
enough get some of this you want some
our whoop yeah you you thought you could
handle the lump it's turns out you could
not oh my god
[Applause]
come here you oh where why help get in
the birdhouse whoo
come here you yeah yeah that's right
good god you suck oh my god you suck
damn it we're good start activating this
side but we're halted by a bunch of
crazy-ass hippies now I've had my fair
share of protests at the sites but this
ain't my first gig but these people were
different they were cloaks and stood
around our cabins in a circle chanting
some gibberish it's not like they can do
anything in us they wouldn't dare lay a
finger on me unless they want our
employer to sue their asses anyway I
tried to get some sleep earlier and
welcome to see that they had gone I
noticed a fair few birds are flying
around up here now hopefully the birds
scared them off work must go ahead
tomorrow regardless of if the people
come back or not the boss isn't gonna
like this yeah I'm not gonna I thought
they were our god it burns heard we were
not gone I'm just gonna go for you know
it oh I'm just gonna go for it diagonal
run it's the old doom method og somes Oh
jiminy Christmas it ain't good okay I'll
be there by me Oh who all of them all of
them okay I'm just gonna go yeah get
some blooms are those blooms Oh hot
fresh blooms what is that whoa what is
that tree what was that tree just
spinning by oh oh what is that oh what
is that oh oh hi oh hi hello hi they
took my god yeah they do Wow
oh it's been a couple days I haven't
slept a wink
caww caww caww God's keys give me a
break this place creeps me out man Birds
everywhere trees everywhere and yet nah
one of my co-workers insight I hope this
is just some elaborate ruse from the
boys I really do
oh and those hippies say I keep seeing I
tell you I don't think there were
hippies man the birds they follow them I
seen it I seen it I tried to get out of
here but we're deep into the forest and
are shipping on with all of our
equipment around and never arrived I'd
kill to be stuck in traffic bad at home
right now yeah me too man yeah me too
I'm gonna rock oh so many
oh so many there they all are where am I
going
bloob I love me some boobs give me the
boobs okay where do I go from here I
don't know little I'll just keep going
this way I guess all right here we go
other blimey oh yes she's very yes oh
good fine as fine is fine oh can I make
it through here oh god I cannot can't I
oh god no oh god please how they all
burn oh wait no I just cut through the
woods wait what but I was here already
what is it I have been here M&A yeah Oh
God Oh was I supposed to go I think I
was just supposed to go through like
some path here in the woods I don't know
man I don't know they're really really
really hustled up right how about I just
just got rump
the lump Oh one oh yeah that's that's
she Benny Christmas
Oh God okay there we go
whoa whoa hey whoa whoa that's not
normal
oh that's so not normal oh my god that's
not normal what is that all about
oh it's not normal okay so I was over
here the path just kind of dead ends in
this Plaza but why oh Jesus
oh hey buddy hey how you doing they took
my goddamn arm they're about to think
something else to use ah come here you
stop you'll leave him alone
oh never mind he's gone he done though
holy [ __ ] oh my god there was so many of
you right there why I'm gonna come back
around for this I think I just might
have seen a path about back this way
oh yeah there's something back here okay
so this is kind of a path yeah yeah
definitely
Oh God Oh why are there weird meat
cocoons in the forest here that I don't
understand Hey look at that is so old
look at that that's no good oh you you
you you you oh god I've lost my sense of
direction
hey where did that thing go that I saw
Oh God okay that's not good okay I gotta
go this way I guess who the birds dude
it is just bloops all right thank you
oh that's that looks good oh I love it
oh I love it oh I love it oh I love it
yeah yeah not today Bartoli's oh yeah
birdy wordy's go boom
one more two more easy busy lemon
squeeze me oh so sad
all gone oh hey sorry that's just the
way the cookie crumbles
hey Church it's a little okay that's
more odd than I thought it was what a
big boy or girl what are you so big okay
why is this my responsibility I
responsible 'ti to deal with Oh Larry's
leg help me oh god help me okay there go
I guess one hit oh hey I can still move
good okay great yeah okay okay okay okay
okay
nissim so god what happened
oh geez
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god okay I know what I know what you
need I know you want good god oh god oh
god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god
oh god oh god oh my god stop that
good God just die okay
okay all right do I burn away all this
[ __ ]
apparently not alright well that was fun
glad I did that
hey Larry's lag how you doing buddy good
to see you Oh Larry go great
alright see you around kid see round
nice door sound effect where'd my
flamethrower go I don't feel good why
looks pretty good pretty good pretty
good pretty good I gotta say it's pretty
good but good pretty good get very good
very good German food very good everyone
want to go stay up-to-date on germ foods
project okay okay this one is called Oh
only in darkness I don't know what's
happening only in darkness but it can't
be good
movement run Crouch flare great all
these are good difficulty
oh man to normal thank you I'm gonna do
normal I'm gonna just normals for me
please one normal use mirror oh I don't
know what that means what do you mean by
mirror Oh
but why what what wait what do you mean
prepare to run what's happening bye oh
geez oh I'm dead I'm dead
am i dead I'm not dead I'm dead
Oh God oh I'm dead oh no no no no no
listen you don't want to do anything
like this to me oh it's red light green
light it's green light my red light oh
okay I get it okay all right this ain't
so bad okay all right no shoot oh oh oh
that felt real close behind me I should
move faster than should I should I get
it I get it I get it I get it
oh okay rebuild the painting what do you
mean rebuild the painting oh wait no
wait no hang on that's not fair Oh Oh
this this is an untidy l-- oh okay
okay I'm rebuilding it why am i building
on wow oh god please no I was trying to
rebuild it I really was I swear I've
been a good boy okay all right
rebuilding rebuilding rebuilding
rebuilding okay last one here we go and
got it okay rebuild it rebuild
well God
okay we're good Wow all right cool I
might get my name on this hey cool good
let's go for it baby easy this games so
easy who'da thunk it was so easy I I'm
going away okay easy
what is the mirror do I don't know who
would know not me
oh boy oh boy
okay we're fine it's so good yeah so far
behind didn't even know who I am
oh come on give me a challenge stupid
so easy never even knew the definition
of not easy oh yeah it's nothing to me I
got hops mad hops biggest goofiest
beefiest hops so hoppy you'd never knew
how hoppy I've been okay I don't even
hear behind me this way yeah you you
ain't never gonna get me you ain't never
gonna get me oh [ __ ] oh god no no not
like this
no I need to get him oh [ __ ] oh God Oh
flare I don't know II aah oh oh oh god
oh god I'm stuck get up get up get up
get up get up Oh God come on come on not
like this oh come on please
oh god please oh thank you thank you
please what am i doing what am i doing
oh [ __ ] thing okay got it
I don't know what do you want what do
you want I don't know what I don't know
what I don't understand
Oh oh shoot oh I don't know I don't know
what what do I do
purple okay
okay I don't understand oh hi hey how
you doing
alright looks like I'm not going on the
leaderboard everybody let's try that
again
alright take tois so easy mind-numbing
ly easy so easy I've got this in the bag
in all of my bags I've got this of all
the bags for me to get I get this
insanity uh-oh
really yo you're gonna dick me like that
oh you're gonna dick me like that you're
gonna dick me midair when I'm trying to
hit any hoop all right you got I got
this this is easy easy he's got it okay
okay yellow purple blue yellow purple
yellow purple blue purple yellow blue oh
[Music]
okay I got that that one was a bit there
was a bit more difficult I should be
more difficult I probably could have
done that brute force style but I didn't
think about okay let's go let's just go
let's go let's not think about it why
would we think about it I'm not thinking
about anything why would I think about
anything I'm not thinking about
something oh it's dork
but not for long oh I don't know where
I'm going where am I going okay here I
go
okay it's a little dork but that's okay
it's alright I got something you gonna
like oh [ __ ] I don't like it I don't
know what the mirrors for I have no idea
maybe it's like a last minute thing if
she's gone about to get me but oh really
that's not appropriate
woo okay hey oh hey why oh why
what oh jeez oh really oh this is not
this not ideal okay I'm going for it
come on let me go for it come on let me
go for it oh yeah what's this oh yeah
through that house sweet nade come on
come on I did it okay thank you
Wow I'm not gonna try hard mode that
sounds like a pain in the ass especially
with the puzzle solving portion of that
but that was cool I like that it was it
was different it was very different from
most horror games I played very rkt very
arcade style and I kind of liked cuz
it's kind of hard to do an arcade style
horror game I like that that's cool then
anyway that is it for three scary games
thank you everybody so much for watching
oh geez let me know what you thought of
these games down in the comments below
and if you've got other scary games that
you want me to play write them in the
comments as well if you haven't checked
out a heist with markiplier please do it
is the best thing I've ever made link is
in the description and thank you
everybody so much for watching it if you
want to help me make other cool projects
like a high school markiplier why not
become a member of the channel click the
join button
down there and see if you can support me
doing these cool projects and get a
sneak peek and future things as they're
being developed and you get weekly
member-only live streams check it out
it's worth it thank you so much for your
support and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]